[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review
of the umbrella academy season two i'm
gonna break down
every episode with all my thoughts on
it's gonna be a big review here now
here's a disclaimer before i jump into
this season review
i was not a fan of umbrella academy
season one
i was actually really turned off by it
and super disappointed i wanna just say
that because
it's gonna make you understand how
shocked and surprised at
my thoughts and feelings on this season
and what i liked so much better about
this season so
episode one really starts with a bang
right away i mean we jump in with each
of our characters here
in different years and it's centered
again
through five but we get these really
awesome action sequences and especially
seeing
the russians attacking america here and
they're all using their superpowers
literally in this one sequence we're
seeing them use their superpowers almost
more than
all of last season which was something i
really was frustrated with season one
where
it's a superhero show and you're waiting
and waiting to see what they do at
points you're forgetting what they even
do as their power but
this season they fixed that and they
really ramped up the action
and i love every character is freshened
up here with a fresh story
but still connecting to arcs that were
built in season one i particularly love
they gave ellen page more screen time in
season two
again another complaint about season one
was this is your star
this is the best actress on the show use
her and they learn that here and they
let her really show her chops by having
her character interestingly enough
forget who she was and what was going on
which really worked well and
it works well because vanya really is
the superman of the group
and that can be a problem with a lot of
superhero stories the big group and one
of them is ultra powerful
we see it all the time and then you
could just say oh why don't they just
save everybody but
it grounds them it grounds her that she
forgot so it's a good
justifiable reason why she's not just
taking everything over i like the angle
at the end of this episode that they're
all relating to five now and the
struggles of time travel
and feeling what he's always complained
about and that feeling of not knowing
what to do
cringe song selection though with diego
here in the looney bin
and they play the acoustic version of
crazy by gnarls barkley i always thought
the music choice in season one were on
the nose just kept that formula going
but i think as the season went on it
went away from that which i really
appreciated and we got some exciting
characters introduced in these
blonde henchmen aka the swedes i love
that one of them is a milkman so episode
one
i would give an 8.1 wasn't the best but
it was definitely improvement already
over season one so
episode two is where i got really more
believing in this show and i'm happy we
got to see the handler survives because
there's so much potential with her from
last season and she really takes over
the season and shines
she is a master manipulator and she is a
big chess player against the other chess
player and five
i also love to see aj the goldfish man
we saw on the trailer
he looks so cool i just love the idea of
that character of being a goldfish head
i actually just wish we had more of him
this season but i feel like
his story isn't over even though he's
been eaten i like that they had luther
running devonia first and him admitting
his guilt
of how they treated vanya and that they
kept that strong theme from last season
going
into this season all the way till the
end of mistreatment of the one
who they originally thought didn't have
powers also this new character of
lila who is diego's love interest and
much much more as the season progresses
the actress here
ritu arya is incredible i was stunned
how good she is so that was exciting to
watch
in general and added some life to
diego's story
she also made diego more likeable
someone he's actually
cares about which he really really
needed because i thought he was so
hateable in season one and what just
shocked me was having just two episodes
with action in it
which really didn't happen much in
season one at all and they were not
shying away here
it's great because the show was always
promoted as a fun show
and it should be a blast to watch and i
just felt season one was so dull but
this season was actually doing that
they knew look like we need more action
we need more
superhero action and they did that they
they gave you something
every episode with action pretty amazing
how that just works and i love
it only enhance the story and characters
and suspense and
you see that here at the end of the
episode where diego in five
really exciting sequence where they go
to find their father and they see little
pogo which was a surprise and we get
this really awesome
duel between the dad and diego with the
crazy cliffhanger thinking diego might
be dead
so this episode for me went up i gave it
an 8.5
so episode three i got worried again i
wasn't so hot about it
i didn't like that they had diego just
healed up by
lila and wasn't really continuing that
exciting cliffhanger moment we had of oh
my gosh he dead it kind of
shows it a couple hours later i'd like
to just have jumped right where we left
off
but so be it i like though we start
really touching base with klaus and ben
here
i like the relationship they've always
had together and they really focused in
on that
and just add so much more weight to
ben's eventual death later on
and i also just want to say about robert
chian he's just a really interesting
case with an actor where
the first couple episodes of season one
i thought he was pretty bad at acting
and then he got
really good all of a sudden and then
this season i just think he's excellent
so
you see that kind of progress and he's
really just
to me the most likable character and a
joy to watch i think he's the one the
audience just feels for the most and
there's a lot of credit due to the actor
himself
and robert sheehan there was some awful
editing here an awful use of breaking
the fourth wall
when you're watching where allison
actually sees klaus
and says i haven't used my powers since
and then it cuts to her
when she used them on vania and actually
shows us the clip come on you can't do
that
like especially in a story you're you're
in the moment with them and then to cut
for that reason it's not a clever way
where maybe you'd see five do it later
in the season
or make sense for his character to do it
because he's explaining something
violence but
that's just ridiculous it's like
throwing a recap into an episode i hated
that
it started also to feel like at some
points not towards the middle but in the
beginning of the story of the civil
rights it kind of felt like a lot of the
marvel shows did
with superhero where it's like they add
in kind of this storyline that
makes it more human and a cause they're
going for but it was really slow at
first when they were just talking about
postponing the sit in and it was like
come on let's let's move it a little
quicker
it does pay off and i think it actually
ended up being great but the beginning
of it was a little
wonky to me and i also really hate in
scenes like this where there's a lot of
background actors when the background
actors are way over the top
they do this a lot in the walking dead
i've always said it's a big complaint of
mine
look everything on screen counts and
extras count and when they're all going
like yeah
or like really angry but to the point
where they're all just repeating the
same actions in the background they look
kind of like
just robots being told what to do i hate
that so i wish
directors would pay more attention to
that and make it feel as real as
possible but
it in this episode you get some of that
payoff i'm talking about in this civil
rights story where it's really timely it
speaks to
the times now with a really tough just
segment to watch with the police
brutality but it was really cool to see
allison use her rumor ability here and
again she uses it
way more than she did all season one
which is just awesome to watch
and it was a nice little touch here at
the end with luther self-sabotaging
himself letting himself get beat up
basically almost to death and then
looking up at the moon
being over crushed over allison and we
get another solid cliffhanger which this
season is full of which i was also
shocked by
every episode made you want to watch the
next one and that cliffhanger being that
we learned as the audience that
lila's mother is the handler but this
one for me was a 7.8
it just didn't feel that groove that the
first
two episodes felt so episode four is one
of the standout episodes of the season
for me
this was the majestic 12 episode i love
this reveal how handler was the one who
got
lyla and and ordered the kill of her
parents i
love how this episode was really the
first one that gave the handler a lot of
screen time this season and embraced her
character and how great it is and they
really made this interesting
relationship between lila and handler
and they didn't have lila just be some
crazy chick love interest for diego they
made her character so much more which
was really
a surprise and awesome i love some humor
here especially with klaus usually with
klaus and he says though
to comfort allison a story about a
scorpion a frog and she's just like what
was the point of the story he's like i
have no idea
and again thematically worked well here
where klaus
sees his lover dave who's trying to
prevent from joining the war
his uncle hits him calls him a queer and
it just
you feel the pain for klaus and it makes
sense then why he would relapse right
after and then we get some big stuff
with diego seeing the real version of
his mother
and that's another reveal and twist and
like seeing little pogo it's cool to see
that the mom was based off his real love
and then we get this moment that i
hadn't felt this kind of feeling in rel
academy yet
it happens here when vanya lifts the
water to save harlan
holy crap was that awesome it was the
first time i felt like this type of show
was really hitting its true potential
and you see the budget they put into
this netflix
looked great and was just really
thrilling to watch and it all leads to
something it leads to her resuscitating
him
and giving him her powers and they made
even luther maybe the least interesting
character
super interesting this season and
funnier and i love the sequence where
he's taking the nitrous
with elliott and they're just laughing
and it gets dark really quick and he's
like my dad left me on the moon and then
we get what i'm talking about another
fun
action sequence now with diego and five
and the swedes and lila and it's just
craziness and
show's really good at action sequences
and they don't rely too much on cgi they
blended in well
with giving us still a lot of
hand-to-hand combat which to me is the
best so this episode for me was an 8.8
now episode five was another standout
one for me
i'm gonna say that four and five were my
two favorite episodes of the season
and evidently they're directed by the
same person and tom varika so there's
something there that's a name to watch
when you see his name pop up on any
episodes of this show
because for me those episodes had the
best rhythm and they stood out the most
we opened this episode with pogo in
1962 and the cgi of him just looks
absolutely amazing
i love the point of view shots we get of
him looking at the mother and
you're just seeing more as the season
goes on which really works
well is that we see here that luther
goes to see his dad and his dad's an
awful prick to him
saying he never wanted children and
we're learning more and more about the
father
through our main character's eyes as
they do and that was just so effective
as the season went on and here it really
picks up pace because then five wants to
get the band back together
and we get all the snarky talk back and
forth between these main characters
i thought funniest moment maybe this
season and funniest running joke in
general though is
having been always being ignored by the
group because of klaus
because he's not mentioning he's there
and they ask about ben he's like
no unfortunately ghosts can't time
travel and ben's like what
i thought that always worked great some
really cool transitions
and editing here is when luther throws
five to travel to sheila i love stuff
like that they really put in that extra
effort one of the weird moments though
in this season was actually when they do
get the band back together
five tells diego and luther to get vanya
i felt like though there was a scene
missing here
how did they get vanya back to their
place so easily he tells him that and
then we see
the next scene she's on the couch
meanwhile she's got all this stuff going
on at the farm and doesn't seem like
she's ready to move yet so that was
strange and they gave
klaus again some just really good lines
and
speaks for the audience in a sense too
like acknowledging
finally someone saying it how it's kind
of weird about alison
and luther having a thing and he gets
this liar he says the best relationship
with his family
was five banging that mannequin that was
so good
and we see how smart of a villain the
handler is by
basically setting up the swedes with
diego's knife and they she booby traps
one of them
and we get this really again awesome
ending sequence of action
just if they keep doing it and it works
definitely for a show like this and
you see lila and five go head to head
which was awesome and there's a nice
touch here of a swedish
adele hello cover as the swedes mourn
one of their own
so this one was also an 8.8 for me so
episode 6 was really good in the sense
it shows you now from allison's point of
view like it did last episode luther's
of what really happened when they first
landed and how tough it would be for a
black person in 1961 so they don't
sugarcoat it they don't hide how it
really would be i think that was
really smart by the creators and writers
here and you see the little details put
in like
really getting you into the timeline of
the 60s
and that's a tribute to production
design costume design but you see like
little photos in the barbershop of
jackie robinson the music playing of
aretha franklin again you see effort
here and it gets
juicy in the storyline where handler is
making offers now to five
and that weird flirting going on between
the handler and five because handler
knows he's really
an older man i think's really funny and
works well but we see allison now she's
showing her powers to rey but she's
going a little
power crazy here when she burns that
guy's hand but strangely the wheels kind
of slowed up a bit this episode which is
fine had to settle out of stage up
especially because it was leading up to
this
light supper sequence which was with the
father
more gold was when allison says i heard
a rumor you punch yourself in the face
to diego that was great
sad we lost elliot here to the swedes
and it's a nice cliffhanger again that
five agrees to this deal with the
handler this one was an 8.1 for me
so i'm going to take back what i just
said i have four and five being the best
two they're the second best two if that
makes any sense
the best episode is episode seven
because this is the first nine i've ever
given this show
we get a crazy opening right away with
five assassinating the board of
directors in 1982.
what an awesome way for hilton to
destroy aj
with the paddle breaking the glass with
the fish in it but keeping the fish i
love how much
gore they do in a tvma show also taking
advantage of that which i love
it was a brutal scene and i love it was
so great again just to build tension in
a ridiculous show like this which makes
it fun is just
the handler giving five the briefcase
like okay you have 90 minutes
just having that clock effect of ticking
come in
really ramps everything up and just
humor with the handler here where
she's telling the whole commission that
the board's den she's taking over but
she used the megaphone too loud at first
and then she says
if they want to talk to someone about it
their health insurance is out of network
so they don't cover it which is great
and i love this
ben possessing cloths to get a feeling
of alive all
working towards the payoff of ben's
full-on death later on
so it's really touching you just want to
talk to that girl and experience
all this one of my favorite camera shots
of the season was actually
when the handler has now aj in the
fishbowl and
she's looking in there and you see how
they make her face look like a monster
with the water i thought that was really
cool
and it's also hysterical she's just
talking to a fish and i loved
seeing now five and vania get tension
here
with him trying to tell her what to do
again because we're seeing the two most
powerful in the group kind of
butt heads here and really good writing
in this episode is when allison's
telling her husband she's got to go but
saying the movement's not even finished
not
even in 2019 again really timely and
paid off well for all the set they had
for
the civil rights movement story and
what's effective about this
is ray her husband saying no i don't
want to forget
because i would take this year with you
remembering that over a lifetime without
you
and you see that happens later on with
[ __ ]
and vania it's a great theme they had
going this season because
it shows you the effect this umbrella
academy of misfits of weirdos has effect
on normal people in a positive way so
it's just
layered writing thematically and it's
really just again this is why it's i
wanted
you to hear i didn't like season one
because it just impressed me what a
turnaround it is for
a show i didn't like and then we get the
swedes fighting allison
and these cool effects with ben coming
in and out of klaus and just super
tense with the clock ticking and they
blow it so like i said this was a nine
for me favorite episode of the season so
episode eight and episode nine is i
think where they both were kind of just
solid for me however thought the
cinematography in this episode was the
best
especially when vanya was being tortured
here like absolutely ridiculous
cinematography so impressive on that
front i like the idea of five
chasing after five and seeing older five
here adding this humor with the side
effects but i
really do think the best parts of these
episodes was the interrogations of vanya
and her
remembering things and kind of keeping
that theme of her
not remembering these traumatic things
but her also maybe
choosing not to so it's like her forcing
to watch that in a really grim dark way
so i'd give that episode 8.5 episode 9
had a really most touching moment
this is where the waterworks came out of
my eyes for me
when ben sacrifices himself for vanya
and has a great monologue beforehand
explaining why she needs to keep going
on and they have them in this like
purgatory
it's the most heroic thing anyone's done
on the show yet so we get kind of a
cliffhanger now for
next season where we see the dad takes
off a mask
and starts eating the majestic 12.
so we never got an answer on that so
that's really interesting in this
episode really
now pushes this main focused timeline
now about the handler
setting up the kill on lila's parents
but she framed it as
aj and really put all the blame on five
this one would get an 8.7 and then
episode 10 is interesting it's a big
finale it's feels almost like a game of
thrones battle here where you got
the commission versus team i like that
we got to see them
again now as a team user powers together
it was cool to see diego hold those
bullets
vanya gets this huge moment now where
she unleashes the beast
in a way that's the right way which was
awesome it's very dark phoenix storyline
for her this season
and i love the twist of lila here where
she mirrors powers i thought that was
cool
however maybe i'm wrong here but it
wasn't clear to me
how long she knew she had these powers
was she just hiding the whole time when
did she find out
again felt like some scenes are missing
here and that was a little strange
i love the moment though where we almost
lost allison she's like
i heard you heard a rumor and then she
uses her rumor trick but
lyla shoots it back and says you
couldn't stop breathing that was crazy
and they did a nice touch here how lila
comes full circle seeing that
just like they are the umbrella academy
they're victims of someone greedy
who acts like a parent but really
doesn't care for them and uses them and
that's shown
really well through diego's monologue to
lila about
weirdness family love all those themes
so he kind of wraps a bow on all the
themes of the season real well and even
it was cool to see five using his
father's voice
giving him wisdom here to just go back a
little in time and he re-does
everyone dying basically so it's cool
lyla actually pieces with suitcase to
leave some room for her story next
season and ellen page i mean
best acting of the season happens here
when she says goodbye to [ __ ] they let
her
really show her chops here i'm not crazy
about harlan still having some power
i also thought it was strange when vania
was explaining about harlan to the group
that
she's tiptoeing constantly this season
about knowing
that he has her power that was also kind
of convenient for the script and i don't
like bringing that
over just this kid with a superpower to
next season but maybe they don't even
touch it we'll see i just didn't think
it was necessary
so to get 2019 the big cliffhanger for
the season is that
the dad's alive the timeline is messed
up and
young ben is there with the sparrow
academy so the finale was really good
i'm giving that one an 8.8 as a whole
you know
i would have given season one probably
uh 5.3
but this i'm giving an 8.8 so in my
memory of such a season one i didn't
like maybe would be
parks and rec into a step up of season
two of parks and rec as an example
of such a dramatic change for me and
like being completely shocked i was so
nervous when i got the screeners for the
season because i was like
how the hell am i gonna get through this
i could not even bear to watch anymore
umbrella academy and
i was stunned i was proven wrong and i'm
really happy i watched it and reviewed
it i think
now the sky is the limit for season
three of this show
as long as they don't hang too much now
on time travel you don't want that to
wear out
and get too messy and confusing i
haven't read the comics so i don't know
where the story goes but i know though
for a show if they keep it that fun
feeling that escapism feeling especially
in times like this
and don't be afraid of action and
realize that
if you just throw in a couple themes and
keep the story interesting enough
and a good villain in the show like this
you'll be fine and i think
it just exploded and showed a lot of
talent this cast really had that was
kind of hindered last season so let me
know what you guys saw this season down
below i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment and try to respond as
many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss any of my reviews of tv shows
movies i do celebrity interviews as well
so you don't miss any of those
and please follow me at stevevarly1 on
twitter instagram for more of me and
i'll see you next time